Evangelikale Netzwerke, das sind kirchliche Strömungen, die ein sehr tradiertes Rollenbild vertreten und oft auch nicht mit einer liberalen Gesellschaft vereinbar sind. Immer mehr Fußballer rechnen sich aber solchen Netzwerken zu. Dazu haben recherchiert Felix Michaelis, er ist freier Journalist, veröffentlicht viel zu Rechtsextremismus, Antisemitismus oder eben Evangelikalismus und Dina Falken, die hier unter Pseudonym teilnimmt. Ich würde sagen, wir legen mal los mit der Sendung. Werte Hörerinnen und Hörer, der Rasenfunk.
So, Borders in God ist ein Disziplin, der in der Welt des Fußballs ein Bewegungsmöglichkeit hat, aber es ist auch ein evangelistisches Bewegungsmöglichkeit, das die Messe erhält. Und du kannst das nicht verfilmt bekommen, ohne den Wort von Gott. Du kannst das nicht. Amen, Benik, Alter. Ich denke mir, Alter, erinnern wir uns mal, wenn wir 16, 17 Jahre alt sind.
Und ja, Felix?
Vielleicht um an diese Wunderheilungen noch anzuknüpfen. Ich hatte ja vorhin davon gesprochen, dass es so Konzertartige Massenevents sind. Und diese Wunderheilungen und Exorzismen, die passieren dann auch innerhalb dieser Events. Also das sollten sich die Zuschauer wirklich mal irgendwie eine Doku zu angucken. Das ist total interessant zu sehen und wahrscheinlich für die meisten auch befremdlich, die da nichts mit zu tun haben, wie das aussieht, wenn da irgendwie so Exorzismen oder Wunderheilungen gemacht werden. Und wie die Leute da irgendwie rumschreien und das austreiben, das ist gar nicht so richtig in Worte zu fassen.
Ja, also das hat seine eigene Faszination, möchte ich mal sagen. Und wichtig ist eben der missionarische Gedanke. Egal wann der bei John Bostock sich bei Ballers in God manifestiert hat, vielleicht war es ja wirklich am Anfang in Anführungszeichen nur ein Bibelkreis mit Gleichgesinnten. Es geht vor allem eben darum, Menschen zu erreichen. Und sie ziehen immer auf Jugend. Das sind auch jugendliche Bewegungen. Und dazu habe ich nochmal ein Beispiel mitgebracht. Das haben wir vorhin im Intro schon mal kurz gehört. Da spricht erst Benik Afobi und dann antwortet ihm John Bostock. Letztlich zeigt er eigentlich sehr offen, was er erreichen möchte.
Du wirst aufgewachsen, es werden bessere Spieler als wir sein. Du wirst besser Fußballer als wir sein, es werden mehr Menschen, die mehr Geld haben als wir. Aber der Passionsschutz für Gott muss da sein und dein Leben wird erfüllt. Und du kannst das Fulfilment ohne den Wort von Gott nicht bekommen. Du kannst das nicht. Amen, Amen, Benek, Bro. Wir sind 16, 17 Jahre alt.
Ich fasse noch mal ganz kurz zusammen für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, denen es auf Englisch jetzt zu schnell ging. Benik Afobi sagt, überleg einfach mal, wie viele Fußballspieler es da draußen gibt, wie viele Menschen wir erreichen können mit der Botschaft Gottes, mit dem, was wir tun. Und John Bostock sagt in der ihm eigenen Art, Amen, armen Bruder. Überleg mal, wenn wir dieses Video hier mit 16 Jahren gesehen hätten, was das mit uns gemacht hatte. Und das zeigt ja Dina, warum. Wir haben schon mal über Nachwuchsleistungszentren und Jugendlichkeit gesprochen. Aber warum es vielleicht wirklich eine Pflicht wäre, dass auch alle Menschen, die sich in solchen Strukturen bewegen, zumindest wissen, dass es solche Bewegungen gibt und eben auch die Gefahren, die da drin liegen können. Denn wie gesagt, von außen sieht ja alles immer erst mal einfach nur hip und christlich und gemeinschaftlich aus. Es kann aber auch in ganz extreme Sphären reingehen.
Ja, und ich finde, das sind die Vereine wirklich in der Pflicht. Ich habe mir schon ein paar von diesen Schutzkonzepten von verschiedenen NLZs angeschaut und dieses Thema kommt da einfach gar nicht vor. Also es wird zwar vor Diskriminierung geschützt, aber dass es da auch manipulative religiöse Einflüsse geben kann, das ist nicht Thema. Und ich verstehe ja jeden Jugendspieler, der sich das wirklich anschaut und denkt, oh, das ist cool, da möchte ich dabei sein, das gibt mir Halt, das ist eine Familie. Und das liegt da wirklich an den Vereinen, dass man da aufklärt, dass man vielleicht gute Alternativen bietet. Wie gesagt, Glaube an sich ist ja nicht falsch und auch nicht gefährlich. Und dass man vielleicht auch eine Ansprechperson hat im Verein für solche Themen.
Und dann, ich würde vorschlagen, wir gehen mal noch ein paar Gruppierungen durch, die es sonst noch so gibt, weil es sind nicht nur die Ballers in God. Und dann habe ich noch ein paar Felix Nmecha Zitate mitgebracht, um auch so ein bisschen den Ton zu setzen, auch warum letztlich es auch zu euren Recherchen gekommen ist. Wir haben zum Beispiel Felix noch die God's Power Germany. Was ist denn die God's Power Germany?
Das ist tatsächlich eine der Initiativen, die wir in unseren Recherchen eigentlich fast gar nicht erwähnt haben, weil die bisher auch eher unauffällig und, ich will nicht sagen irrelevant, aber auf jeden Fall eher eine kleinere Initiative sind. Die haben knapp 7000 Follow-In auf Instagram. Das ist wie der Name schon verreden, Deutschsprachige Initiative zur Missionierung. Der Gründer ist Jake Bokey. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihn richtig ausspreche. Und der tritt unter anderem auch als Redner, zum Beispiel bei der Church of Pentecost Germany auf. Im Vergleich zu anderen Gruppen sind sie bisher aber weniger aktiv und relevant. Da gäbe es in Deutschland zum Beispiel Fußballmitvisionen, die da deutlich größer sind, mit denen wir uns mehr beschäftigt haben.
Ich will kurz ganz kurz erklären, warum ich die hier mit genannt habe. Weil hier haben wir mal einen von ganz wenigen Fällen, in denen es ein Posting gab bei dem Spieler, in dem Fall Spieler der U19 von Union Berlin aus dem Männerteam, eben von God's Power Germany verwendet wurden, um Werbung dafür zu machen. Und der Verein ist tatsächlich eingestritten. Ich weiß nicht, Dina, inwieweit ihr da involviert war, das mitverfolgt habt?
Ich habe es gesehen. Ich habe auch Union Berlin angeschrieben und darauf hingewiesen. Und sie haben dann, ich weiß, es ist schon so lange her und es ist so viel passiert, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, was sie geantwortet haben. Aber ich weiß, es war so in der Richtung von, wir haben damit nichts zu tun. Und sie schauen, dass der Post gelöscht wird.
Und das ist dann auch passiert. Und danach haben sie gesagt, wir sind frei von religiösen Botschaften. Das war quasi die Begründung, mit der man das getan hat. Aber deswegen wollte ich das eben hier mal nennen, weil da tatsächlich mal ein Verein tätig geworden ist. Eigentlich fast allen anderen Beispielen, über die wir jetzt reden, haben Vereine höchstens auf öffentlichen Druck hin. Das war dann ja unter anderem auch bei Felix Nmecha der Fall, sich mal geäußert. Felix, du hast schon mehrfach Fußball mit Vision erwähnt. Was ist das für eine Gruppierung? Was müssen wir über die wissen?
Das ist eine deutschsprachige Plattform für Missionierung und es ist ein formal eingetragener Verein der Gründer. Und ja, Vorsitzende ist Manuel Büller, der ist auch Theologe. Und hier wieder, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, der ist Ex-Fußballprofi. Das ist ein Muster, was sich durch diese Organisation zieht und auch insbesondere bei Fußball mit Vision. Da sitzen im Vorstand und im Kader von diesem Verein relativ viele Ex-Fußballer oder sogar zum Teil noch aktive FußballerInnen. Und ja, also Fußball mit Vision muss man wissen, die haben 60.000 Follower auf Instagram. Der Versprecher kommt, weil als wir angefangen haben, hatten diese um die 20.000, 30.000. Und wie gesagt, dass wir angefangen haben, die Texte zu schreiben, ist jetzt acht Monate her oder so. Also da gab es ein sehr, sehr großes Wachstum, ähnlich wie bei Ballers and God. Und insgesamt sehen Dina und ich auf jeden Fall, dass sie sich in den vergangenen Monaten sehr stark professionalisiert haben. Die haben ihren Website-Auftritt überarbeitet. Der sieht jetzt deutlich besser aus. Jetzt mal so wertend gesagt, die haben ihre Insta-Posts überarbeitet und deutlich mehr Reichweite insgesamt. Und die Missionierung funktioniert hier eigentlich same same wie bei Ballers and God. Also es gibt Posts von FußballerInnen, wie sie sich zum Glauben bekennen. Prominentes Beispiel, wieder ein Matcher. Oder wie gesagt, diese sogenannten Zeugnisvideos, die Fußballmitvisionen auf ihrem eigenen YouTube-Kanal hochladen, wo FußballerInnen oder zum Teil auch FunktionärInnen sich zum Glauben bekennen und ihren Glaubensweg erzählen. So weit unproblematisch erst mal.
Und sich wurden da Videos produziert. Bekanntere Namen, die da involviert sind, ist unter anderem Felix Udukay, der Mitgründer ist und im Vorstand sitzt. Eduard Löwen und Enrico Valentini. Also wir haben auch viele ehemalige oder aktuelle 60 Spieler mit drin. Und Giovanna Hofmann, die ich ja vorhin schon erwähnt habe, die ist auch bei Fußball mit Vision dabei. Und das ist jetzt aber so ein klassisches Beispiel, Dina, für eine Organisation, wo man auch auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so viele Anhaltspunkte für Kritik finden muss. Wenn man dann allerdings hört, dass zum Teil des Konzepts im Wesentlichen dazu gehört, junge Menschen dem christlichen Glauben näherzubringen, dann wird man schon ein bisschen vorsichtiger, eben wegen der Schutz junger Menschen. Und wenn man dann hört, dass dazu eben auch Fußballerbibeln verteilt werden und Schulen besucht werden, in denen diese Bibeln verteilt werden, wo ja nicht immer ganz klar ist, hat jetzt jeder Jugendliche und jeder hat da jeder jetzt zugestimmt, dass jetzt hier eine christliche Veranstaltung kommt mit einem visionarischen Eifer? Oder war das vielleicht die Idee von einigen wenigen? Dann wird das eben ein bisschen schwieriger auszuhalten, wenn man nicht ganz genau weiß, wofür Fußball mit Vision eigentlich stehen möchte. Wie gehst du denn damit um und lässt sich dazu eigentlich so stichfest etwas sagen? Welche Art des Glaubens Fußball mit Vision da verbreiten will?
Ja, es ist bei Fußball mit Vision ein bisschen komplizierter. Sie sind ein bisschen vorsichtiger als jetzt Bolles in God. Wir haben bei unserem zweiten Text, glaube ich, Felix, war das, komplett über Fußball mit Vision eigentlich geschrieben. Woher sie kommen, zu welchen Gruppierungen sie gehören. Sie haben eine gewisse Nähe zu Neues Leben. Das ist eine evangelikale Gruppierung. Die sind da ein bisschen verstrickt miteinander. Ich bin extra so ein bisschen nicht so ganz deutlich, weil das wirklich sehr kompliziert ist. Man sieht es wieder, wenn man tiefer geht, was sie genau machen. Sie haben im Team zum Beispiel einen U16-Trainer vom FC Augsburg, einen Nachwuchsleiter von Alemannien Aachen, die U19-Trainerin der Frauen-Nationalmannschaft. Es geht wieder, wie du gesagt hast, auf die Jugendlichen. Wenn ich ein konkretes Beispiel nennen darf, das ist Sima Susso von Fortuna Düsseldorf, ein Profi-Spieler. Der hat selbst gesagt, dass Manuel Bühler auf ihn zugekommen ist, ihn auf Instagram angeschrieben hat, weil er ein Bibel-Verse in der Biografie hatte und ihn dann mit zur Freikirche Köln-Ostheim genommen hat. Die Freikirche Köln-Ostheim hat öffentlich auf YouTube sehr queerveindliche Predigten, wo sie sich unter anderem als Sünde bezeichnen, unnatürlich oder auch sagen, dass homosexuelle Menschen ihre Orientierung verändern oder umkehren sollten. Sima Susso ist heute, wenn man auf die Homepage von Fussball mit Vision geht, bei Team, im Jugendbereich tätig. Seine Aufgabe ist eigentlich, die Jugendlichen zu Fussball mit Vision führen. Ich persönlich finde es wahnsinnig problematisch, wenn man dann in so einer Freikirche ist.
Oder sich zumindest nicht davon distanziert, was dort unter anderem gepredigt wird, Felix.
Ja, genau, im Grunde ist es wieder eine Parallele zu Ballos and God. Weil wir haben Manuel Bühler, der schon öfter für die Freikirche Köln-Ostheim als Redner auftrat. Und ich möchte noch mal den Punkt von Dina wirklich betonen. Also die haben eine schon, das muss man so sagen, sehr quälfeindliche Auslegung des Glaubens. Der Hauptprediger, ich mein es ist der Hauptprediger, der da predigt André Töfs. Der hat so was gesagt, was Dina gerade schon sagte, dass Homosexualität eine Sünde ist. Zitat, da predigt auch jemand wie Olaf Latzel regelmäßig. Olaf Latzel, der kommt tatsächlich aus meiner Gegend, hier kennt man den, aber weniger aus grümlichen Gründen. Der von CSD-Teilnehmerinnen, meine ich, als Degenerationsform der Gesellschaft gesprochen hat. Zitat. Und ein Beispiel, was ich jetzt noch anbringen wollte, ist Valentini. Was du schon meintest, der ist mit dem Vorstand von Fußball mit Vision und gleichzeitig U14-Trainer von Nürnberg. Und Valentini, da gab es Anfang des Jahres, das haben wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viele mitbekommen, aber um ihn gab es auch so einen Skandal, unter anderem auch Bild, die Bild-Zeitung aufgenommen hatte und zwar hatte er, um es wirklich sehr vorsichtig zu sagen, verwirrende Aussagen über Homosexualität gesagt. Im Grunde hat er sich ablehnend gegenüber Homosexualität geäußert und wie gesagt, es ist sehr problematisch, wenn so jemand gleichzeitig Trainer bei einer U14 in Nürnberg ist und da potenziell mutmaßlich Einfluss nehmen könnte auf SpielerInnen. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen weitergegriffen, aber es gibt gerade in der Bundesliga keinen einzigen geouteten Spieler und das hat sicherlich auch was damit zu tun, dass das auch aus solchen Gründen nicht akzeptiert werden würden.
Und das ist eben das, was Fußball mit Vision so interessant macht, dass eben hier so deutlich in den Jugend- und Nachwuchsbereich reingegangen wird. Wir haben auch Bernd Breitmaier mit dabei. Das ist ein Berater von Fußballer mit Vision. Fußball mit Vision, aber sind vielleicht auch Fußballer mit Vision, stimmt vielleicht auch darauf zu. Der ist inzwischen ein christlicher Berater. Das ist jetzt ein Zitat von ihm. Er hat das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum von Hannover 96 mit aufgebaut. Wir haben ja eben auch mit Melanie Behringer, die Coach des Frauen-Nationalteams der U19 beim DFB ist, jemanden, der dort arbeitet bei diesem Verband. Ich weiß, dass ihr all die betroffenen Organisationen konfrontiert habt und eben einfach nachgefragt habt, ob ihnen das bewusst ist und ob das zusammengeht mit den Werten der Organisation. Was hat denn der DFB in diesem Fall gesagt?
Ja, der DFB hat uns gegenüber betont, dass Behringers Glaube auf christlicher Nächsten, Liebe und Toleranz beruhe.
Und hat man sich geäußert zu, ob sie jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn sie lesbische Spielerinnen hätte, ob das für sie einfach so okay ist und das unberührt bleibt von ihrem persönlichen Glauben?
Sie haben sich auch relativ kurz gefasst. Sie haben uns einfach nur bestätigt, dass mein Behringer die Werte des Verbandes, wie Vielfalt und Respekt, lebe.
Und das wollen wir natürlich auch so akzeptieren. Aber das zeigt für euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, glaube ich, wie kritisch dieser ganze Bereich zu sehen ist. Weil dem kann natürlich so sein. Glaube ist, wie gesagt, Privatsache. Aber hier haben wir es eben mit der Einflussnahme von schutzbefohlenen Menschen zu tun. Und dann ist es eben doch nicht so klar, in welche Richtung das geht. Vor allem, wir haben ja schon rausgearbeitet, denn wir wissen, diese Gruppierungen arbeiten mit einem missionarischen Eifer und vertreten eben nicht immer liberale Themen. Und damit würde ich sagen, landen wir jetzt dann zum zehnten Mal bei Felix Nmecha. Und jetzt lasst doch mal drüber sprechen, was er so gesagt hat, was er getan hat und warum er eben für den deutschen Diskurs so wichtig ist. Weil wir haben ja schon rausgehört, also er war letztlich auch der Anstoß für eure Recherchen. Ich würde mal einen Zitat von ihm einspielen aus der Ballers in God Podcast Folge mit ihm, wo man so ein bisschen, ja ich glaube, einen Eindruck bekommt, wie er seinen Glauben versteht. Ich sage das jetzt einfach mal ganz wertneutral.
Ohne ihn hätte ich nicht die Chance. Und dann gibt er mir auch die Kraft, er gibt mir die Verbreitung, er gibt mir die Selbstverfassung, und all diese Dinge sind von Gott, deswegen verdient er die Glauben. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass Gott mich und die Fußballer die Wahrheit mit der Plattform teilen.
Halleluja, Mann! Halleluja!
Das ist so, so gut! Halleluja!
Also das kam wieder nicht von uns, aber das habt ihr glaube ich gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Vielleicht übernehme ich das in den Rasenfunk. Die machen das so häufig, dass sie am Ende eines Punkts, Denen, der je was andere sagt, Amen oder Hallelujah reinrufen. Also was hat Felix Nmecha hier gesagt? Er hat gesagt, er fühlt sich als von Gott berufen und deshalb wäre es eben aus seiner Ansicht nicht richtig einfach nur ein Fußballspieler zu sein, sondern eben mit dem, was er tut und damit auch indirekt mit seiner Reichweite, das ist jetzt eine Anmerkung meinerseits, eben das Wort Gottes zu verbreiten und eben den Glauben an Gott. Und da ist ja dann die Frage, Felix, wie macht denn das Felix Nmecha unter anderem so?
Also erst mal, du hast es schon gesagt, er sagt ganz offen, er hat eine klar missionarische Intention. Das macht er einerseits, indem er wie gesagt für diese zwei Gruppierungen auftritt, für Fußball mit Visionen, zum Beispiel Zeugnisvideos. Bei Bollas gegen Gott auch so eine Art Zeugnisvideos. Da leitet er meiner Meinung nach, Dina, korrigier mich, wenn ich falsch liege, auch so eine Bibelgruppe. Oder hat er es zumindest mal? Und ja, es zeigt halt einfach, meiner Meinung nach ist diese Vorbildfunktion sehr wirkmächtig und das Gefährliche daran. Was ich anfangs schon sagte, ich habe das Gefühl, dass gerade ein sehr junges Publikum das nicht auseinanderhalten kann, wenn ihr Vorbild etwas sagt, was man vielleicht nicht einfach so akzeptieren sollte. Und da in dem Moment dann nicht mehr den Fußballer von der Privatperson oder das Vorbild von dem Gesagten, besser gesagt, auseinanderhalten können. Die Missionierung findet sicherlich natürlich auch über sein Social Media statt. Also er hat eine verdammt große Reichweite auf Instagram. Ich weiß jetzt nicht im Kopf, wie viel Reichweite er hat, wie viele Followerin er hat. Aber auch darüber erreicht er viele Leute.
Und Dina, nachdem Felix Nmecha für dich der Anlass war, sich überhaupt mit diesem Thema auseinanderzusetzen. Also das, was wir hier gerade gehört haben, das hat er noch als Wolfsburg-Spieler gesagt vor seinem Wechsel zum BVB. Was waren denn die Dinge, über die du gestolpert bist, als du dich mit Felix Nmecha auseinandergesetzt hast?
Ja, das waren einerseits die beiden Instagram-Storyposts, die damals in den Medien waren. Also das war dieses Pride, was er mit dem Teufel gleichsetzt. Und dann war es noch eins, das habe ich jetzt gerade vergessen.
Er hat sich dann noch beim Tod von Charlie Kirk geäußert, das war aber später. Es gab noch verschiedene Likes für queerfeindliche Posts, in denen eben, also es gab einen Post, da schreibt jemand, jemand, der Christ ist, kann nicht schwul oder lesbisch sein. Und das zum Beispiel hat er gelesen.
Und ein Post von Matt Walsh.
Ja, genau, dieser Post von Matt Walsh war damals noch in den Medien. Ich habe da dann eben diesen Post gefunden, wo einer schreibt, dass man, wenn man Christ ist, nicht schwul oder lesbisch sein kann, weil man ja dann nicht in den Himmel kommt. Er hat viele Posts geliked, die Likes hat er dann allerdings alle entfernt oder entfernen lassen, ich weiß es nicht. Wo es halt auch darum ging, dass ein Homosexueller durch Gott dann heterosexuell wurde. Also es ging damals ziemlich in eine eindeutige Richtung. Und das war ja nicht alles. Man könnte ja meinen, okay, jetzt ist er bei Borussia Dortmund, es gab damals einen Skandal, es wurde richtig groß. Jetzt ist es gut, nein, eben da war dieser Charlie Kirk Post. Und dann dieses frauenfeindliche Buch, was er ja noch gelesen hat.
Könnte dazu noch kurz was sagen, weil das war jetzt ja kein Post, sondern man konnte es quasi in einer Story des BVB sehen, dass dieses Buch neben ihm lag. Was ist denn das für ein Buch? Also warum ist ein Buch an sich so schlimm?
Ja, also das Buch, das heisst Understanding the Purpose and Power of Woman, God's Design for Female Identity, das ist von Miles Monroe. Das ist ein evangelikaler Prediger und Pastor. Und in dem Buch erklärt er eigentlich die Rolle der Frau. Ihr merkt es vielleicht an meiner Stimme, dass ich das nicht so geil finde. Er sagt eigentlich, die Frau ist eine Verstärkerin des Mannes. Die Frau ist das Spiegelbild des Mannes und die Frau hat einfach die Aufgabe, eine Lebensspenderin zu sein, Kinder zu machen. Es bespricht auch, wie ein Mann sich einer Frau gegenüber zu verhalten hat. Ich habe das Buch gelesen, das muss man ihm zugestehen. Er sagt, wie sich ein Mann korrekt verhalten soll. Aber es bleibt die Rolle der Frau, sich unterzuordnen, ihren Mann unterzuordnen und wirklich ihre Rollen einzunehmen. Das finde ich sehr problematisch.
Unter anderem korrigiere ich mich, wenn ich das falsch herausgeschrieben habe, aber wird darin beschrieben, dass Frauen wie ein Rohmaterial, ich zitiere jetzt, sein, dass von den Männern geformt werden müsse. Also der Umgang wird einem beigebracht, aber auch, wie man quasi die Frauen zum eigenen Spiegelbild macht.
Genau, genau. Und wenn man das sieht, dass da ein Bundesligaprofi, ein ja, teilweise auch Nationalspieler, dieses Buch dann an einem öffentlichen Ort liest. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es im Teamhotel war, aber es war halt auf einer Terrasse, es war öffentlich einsehbar, man hat es ja eben auch nachher auf Social Media gefunden. Da frage ich mich dann auch wieder, wo ist die Vorbildfunktion?
Ich meine, man muss dazu sagen, das war jetzt kein Video, was er gepostet hat. Also er hat sich gesagt, hier, ich habe einen Buchtyp für euch, bitte lest mal dieses Video. Aber ich finde es halt insofern relevant und deswegen auch berichtenswert, weil Felix Nmecha nach allen Aufregern, die es um ihn gab, ich formuliere es jetzt flapsig mal als Aufreger, ja immer wieder betont hat, ich paraphrasiere jetzt, ja so habe ich es ja nicht gemeint, so schlimm, wie ihr es alle findet. Und dementsprechend ist dann die Frage, können wir ihm das glauben? Und wenn wir dann eben ein solches Buch bei ihm liegen sehen und eben dann jemand wie du dieses Buch auch komplett liest, ich ziehe sämtliche Hüte, die ich habe, ehrlich gesagt, wie du das durchgehalten hast, und dann eben sehen, was dort drin steht in einem solchen Buch, dann lässt das zumindest Zweifel zu, ob dem wirklich so ist, dass er manche Dinge, die er gemacht hat, nicht so gemeint hat. Ich meine, in diesem Buch wird die LGBTQ-Bewegung als Vergewaltigung der Bürgerrechtsbewegung bezeichnet. Also das ist jetzt auch kein Buch, wo man zwischen den Zeilen lesen muss, um rauszulesen, was dahinter der Sinn ist. Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist es auch okay, dass wir darüber reden, dass da einfach nur ein Buch neben Felix Nmecha lag. Felix?
Ich glaube, dieses Zitat, was du gerade angebracht hast mit der Vergewaltigung der Bürgerrechtsbewegung, das hat der Autor, der Prediger irgendwann mal so gesagt. Ich habe das Buch nicht gelesen, aber das ist nicht drin.
Das hat er mal gesagt.
Okay, gut, dass ihr das eingeordnet habt. Sorry, das sieht man mal. Das ist gut. Obwohl man versucht sauber zu arbeiten, rutscht einem dann sowas durch. Wir hören mal kurz einen weiteren Ausschnitt von Felix Nmecha, wie er sich geäußert hat im Bollers in God Podcast.
Das ist etwas, das Gott mir letztes Jahr wirklich geholfen hat. Dodi Lukabaki war auch bei mir in Wolfsburg. Er ist ein anderer Bollers in God-Member. Wir haben uns alle geholfen und wir haben so viele Erinnerungen während der Saison bekommen. Einer der größten Erinnerungen, die wir bekommen, war, dass wir leben und spielen durch das Ziel, nicht durch die Gelegenheit. So lange ich hart arbeite, so lange ich in Gott abide, werde ich mein Ziel erreichen. Diese zwei Schläge waren wirklich wichtig für mein Entwicklung.
Alter, das ist so krass.
Das war eine Bar, Alter.
Sag das mal noch einmal für die Leute.
Wir leben durch das Ziel und nicht durch die Möglichkeit.
Amen.
Also was hat Felix Nmecha hier ganz kurz gesagt? Im Grunde hat er gesagt, jedes Mal, wenn ich den Platz betrete, dann spiele ich nicht für mich, sondern ich spiele für God. Das hätte er eben gelernt in einer härteren Zeit bei Wolfsburg. Damals hatte er nicht so viel Einsatzzeit und dass man eben für sein Schicksal lebe, für seine Bestimmung lebe. Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich die korrektere Übersetzung hier und nicht für die Möglichkeit und dann Klammer auf, Geld zu verdienen, Tore zu erzielen, Titeln und Trophäen zusammen. Dina, wenn man jemandem so sprechen hört, verändert das auch die Art und Weise, wie wir über ihn als Fußballspielenden denken sollten? Wenn er sagt, jedes Mal wenn ich auf den Platz gehe, ist das, okay, ich überspitze jetzt, ist das quasi wie ein Gottesdienst?
Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Ich denke nicht, weil da sind wir ja wieder bei dem Persönlichen. Sein Glaube ist, auch wenn er evangelikal sein sollte und auch wenn er all diese Ansichten, die man ihm vorwirft, hat, was man ja nicht zu 100%ig weiss, ist sein Glaube immer noch persönlich für Felix Nmecha. Und wenn er für sich sagt, ich gehe nur aus diesem Grund auf den Platz und spiele Fußball, dann finde ich das okay.
Felix, hast du da Gedanken zu?
Ich sehe das eigentlich genauso wie Dina. Ich würde vielleicht noch auf eine andere Stelle von diesem Zitat zu sprechen kommen, die du jetzt so gar nicht übersetzt hast. Und zwar sagt er ja auch wieder, dass es solange er richtig glaubt an Gott, dass es sportlich auch läuft. Das sagt er so, wenn mich mein Englisch jetzt nicht völlig im Stich gelassen hat. Und das ist das, was ich Anfang schon sagte, dass Dina und ich glauben, dass das dieses wirkmächtige Versprechen ist, was einige dieser Kreise implizit oder explizit geben. Wenn du richtig glaubst, richtig auslebst, dann läuft es sportlich auch bei dir. Und das sieht man, dass das scheinbar bei EMM so im Kopf festgesetzt ist. Das finde ich ganz interessant hervorzuheben.
Ja, kann ich noch hinzufügen, dass es, wenn er selbst das für sich sagt, finde ich das völlig okay. Wenn jetzt er aber sagt, mein Mitspieler, der auch gläubig ist, hey, du schießt die Tore, du hast nur Erfolg, weil Gott das will, dann finde ich es wieder nicht okay, weil es dann eigentlich den eigenen Erfolg, die eigentliche Arbeit schweckt und eigentlich alles Gott zuschiebt, sozusagen.
Ich finde, es zeigt halt, warum im Leistungssport das so anschlussfähig ist. Weil im Leistungssport du die ganze Zeit mit Erfolg und Versagen zu tun hast, mit Gelingen und Nicht-Gelingen, mit Sieg und Niederlage. Und wenn du dann in allem, sowohl im Sieg als auch in der Niederlage, immer etwas Höheres erkennen kannst, dich letztlich damit ja auch emotional distanzieren kannst, was dir helfen kann im Leistungssport, dann hat das eine extreme Wirkmacht. Und deswegen ist das, glaube ich, auch gerade im Fußball eben so anschlussfähig und gerade bei jungen Spielern, weil die genau damit normalerweise ihre Kämpfe haben. Wie gehe ich damit um mit Rückschlägen? Und das müssen nicht immer nur Verletzungen sein, sondern eben auch Dinge, die auf dem Feld passieren. Und gleichzeitig steckt dann aber hinter vielem, was Felix Nmecha so glaubt, dann doch eine dichotome Weltsicht, nenne ich es mal. Auf der einen Seite ist Gott, und auf der anderen Seite ist der Teufel.
Und obwohl wir uns immer sagen können, wir haben die Waffe gewonnen, das ist wahr, wir haben die Waffe gewonnen. Aber wir haben nicht alle Waffen gewonnen. Deswegen müssen wir diese Wahrheit erinnern, weil der Teufel da ist.
Also selbst wenn man als Christ sagen könnte, wir haben den Krieg gewonnen, aber die schlachten noch nicht alle, denn der Teufel, er ist immer noch da und deshalb müssen wir weiter die Botschaften von Gott und Jesus weitertragen. Und da sieht man eben, Felix, da hat das eine ganz andere Tonalität. Und deswegen habe ich diese, diese, diese... Ich hab mir schon mehrere O-Töne mitgebracht, weil man eben merkt, auf einmal wirkt Felix Nmecha ganz anders, wenn er so etwas sagt im Vergleich zu dem, wo wir alle vorher auch gesagt hätten, ja ist er völlig okay, wenn er halt an Gott glaubt, während er Fußball spielt.
Ja, das ist irgendwie so ein ganz klassisches Weltendungsszenario, was hier aufgemacht wird, was natürlich Leute unter Druck setzen kann. Und er bezieht sich da auf den Teufel. Und jetzt, wenn man das mal zurückbezieht auf diesen Post, den er da in seiner Story mal gemacht hat, wo die Pride-Bewegung meines Erachtens nach wirklich unmissverständlich die Pride-Bewegung, also die LGBTQ-Bewegung nur gemeint gewesen sein kann, mit dem Teufel verglichen wird, stellt sich natürlich der Frage, wen sieht denn Nmecha jetzt als Teufel? Wer ist für ihn der Teufel? Also, wer ist Auslöser für dieses Weltendungsszenario, für dieses ganz düstere Szenario, was er da zeichnet? Und ja, das finde ich sehr bedenklich.
Deswegen wollte ich es in dieser Reihenfolge mitbringen. Und Dina, du darfst dann gerne zum letzten, also ich verspreche, ist jetzt auch der letzte Otto von Felix Nmecha, dass ich noch zu äußern. Denn wir haben ja gesehen, es gab Kontroverse. Man muss noch dazu sagen, dass das ist alles passiert dann, als er dann Spieler bei Dortmund war. Also das meiste davon ist dann passiert. Dortmund hat irgendwann dann auch durchgesetzt. Okay, wenn du selber was posten willst, gucken wir nochmal drüber. Ist natürlich toll, dass man auf diese Art und Weise darauf reagiert, indem man sagt, wir wollen nicht, dass du nochmal einen Fehler machst. Interessant finde ich aber, dass Felix Nmecha sich genau dazu geäußert hat, nämlich zu der Frage, wie trete ich denn eigentlich in der Öffentlichkeit auf, wenn ich meine Botschaft unters Volk bringen möchte? Hören wir mal rein.
Ich glaube, dass es eine Balance von Wissen und Wahrheit gibt, in der ich glaube, dass es Situationen gibt, in denen wir nicht so gut darüber reden, dass es nicht so witzig ist, das zu sagen.
Aus der Sicht nach würde Gott von ihm fordern, dass er eine Balance findet zwischen Wahrheiten und dem Teilen dieser Wahrheiten, dass es einen Moment gäbe, Wahrheiten nicht zu teilen, vor allem bei Themen, die er nennt, sie touchy sind, also vielleicht ein bisschen kritikfähiger. Was könnte er damit nur meinen? Vielleicht hast du dazu auch Gedanken. Und dass er es aber so empfindet, dass es letztlich seine Aufgabe ist, im Namen Gottes, sich auch als öffentliche Figur zu solchen Themen zu äußern. Wie denkst du dazu?
Ja, also mit seinen touchy Themen denke ich, meint er schon auch die queeren Themen und die frauenfeindlichen Themen. Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, was so ein bisschen touchy ist. Man sieht es ja, er spricht von der Wahrheit und er spricht von seiner und Gottes Wahrheit. Ich glaube auch, dass er das glaubt. Er ist davon überzeugt, dass in der Bibel, das, was dort steht zu diesen Themen, dass das die Wahrheit ist und dass es seine Aufgabe als öffentliche Person ist, das auch auszusprechen. Und den Menschen zu zeigen, dass wir jetzt eigentlich auf einem falschen Weg sind.
Auf dem aus seiner Sicht falschen Weg, natürlich. Und eigentlich Felix muss man ihm ja dankbar sein, dass er das so offen mal gesagt hat, weil damit ist er klar, er ist sich völlig bewusst, was er tut.
Ja, das denke ich auch. Also bei Nmecha ist es spätestens nachdem es, also es gab mehrere Entschuldigungen und nach diesen Entschuldigungen sind trotzdem immer wieder Sachen passiert. Der letzte Stand war, das ist wieder mal seitens des BVBs die Aussage gab, wir suchen das Gespräch mit ihm und es wird aber auch öffentlich überhaupt nicht kommuniziert, was bedeutet ist, dass das Gespräch gesucht wird, was ist das Resultat davon. DFB hat einen ähnlichen O-Ton gegeben. Und ich persönlich finde das irgendwie einfach schrecklich, weil ich meine, der BVB ist ein Verein, der sich ja Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Danke höhe, für die nächste Liebe und Borussia verbindet, Stichwort Borussia verbindet einsetzt. Also Nmecha als Person widerspricht dem ja, also fundamental in diesem Grundsatz, den der BVB propagiert. Und das finde ich, um ehrlich zu sein, sehr fragwürdig. Natürlich ist es irgendwie schwierig, einen Umgang damit zu finden. Also soll man den jetzt rauswerfen? Das wird realistisch gesehen auch niemals passieren. Aber ja, also das ist meine persönliche Meinung. Ich denke, er ist sich schon sehr sicher, was er davon sich gibt und was er sagt.
Und das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, Dina, warum wir jetzt Felix Nmecha hier so oft nennen, weil er derjenige ist, der am öffentlichsten mit seiner Meinung sich äußert. Bei vielen, vielen anderen können wir Vermutungen anstellen, wie wohl so ihr missionarischer Eifer, den sie ja haben, also den haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, bei allen, die wir so genannt haben, weil das ja auch Teil der Netzwerke ist, in denen sie stecken. Aber welche, welche Glaubensüberzeugung damit verbunden sind, das ist eben von außen nicht zu beurteilen. Aber Felix Nmecha, der hat sich eben geäußert. Er hat sich queerfeindlich geäußert. Er ist vermutlich auch eher einem tradierten Rollenbild zwischen Männern und Frauen anhängig. Und letztlich wird aber ja dann an diesem sehr prominenten Fall gezeigt. So richtig was passiert ist ja nicht.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Und ich kann sagen, als BVB-Fan, ich habe oft das Gespräch gesucht mit dem Verein. Intern hat man das Problem wahrscheinlich schon gesehen, aber machen konnte trotzdem niemand was. Und jetzt gerade auch die Vertragsverlängerung, diesen Frühling mit ihm, zeigt ja auch, dass er zwar gegen fast alle Werte vom Verein verstösst, aber solange es sportlich funktioniert, ist das völlig egal. Und das ist einfach, ich sage es jetzt ein bisschen böse, ich glaube als queere Fan darf ich das schon auch so sagen. Das ist einfach ein Witz und man kann den BVB und seine Werte so einfach auch nicht ernst nehmen.
Was uns zum letzten Punkt bringt, Felix, kannst du gerne gleich mal anschließen, nämlich der Frage, ja welche Verantwortung tragen denn dann Spielerinnen, Vereine und Verbände?
Ja, also zur Personalie, ein Matcher würde ich noch einmal gerne ergänzen. Es gab jetzt neulich die Vertragsverlängerung. Das ist meiner Meinung nach bei dieser Geschichte auch nicht irrelevant. Also der BVB hat den Vertrag mit Felix Nmecha verlängert, ihn zum Topverdiener gemacht und im Prinzip eigentlich zum Aushängeschild. Das kann man schon so zynisch sagen. Also es gibt scheinbar auch nicht irgendwie das Interesse, wenigstens zu sagen, ja, er passt nicht zu unseren Werten. Dann sollten wir ihn vielleicht verkaufen. Das ist noch irgendwie die einvernehmlichste Art und Weise, mit dieser Geschichte umzugehen. Das gibt es nicht. Also ohne Verein und Verbände geht diese ganze Geschichte einfach nicht. Das muss man, das muss man so sagen. Es müssen klare Signale vom Verein, von den Verbänden kommen, bezüglich des Schutzes von Spielerinnen, vor allen Dingen Nachwuchsleistungszentren, aber auch eben klare Konsequenzen. Bisher gab es es eigentlich, wenn überhaupt, von Seiten der Fangemeinden kommuniziert, sei es durch Spruchbanner oder zum Teil, wo Dina und ich jetzt eingeladen wurden, von irgendwelchen Faninitiativen. Aber so richtig von Seiten der Vereine gab es eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt, überhaupt kein Interesse daran, dieses Thema anzugehen.
Warum, Dina, glaubst du, ist das so?
Ja, das ist die große Frage. Ich denke, bei gewissen Vereinen kann man es schon ein bisschen so nennen, dass sie die Werte nur aufgestellt haben, weil es gesellschaftlich ein bisschen verlangt wurde in den letzten Jahren. Ich glaube, es gibt Vereine, die fühlen oder leben nicht, was in den Werten steht. Dann gibt es die Vereine, die wahrscheinlich ein bisschen überfordert sind mit dem Thema, eben weil es ja die Religionsfreiheit betrifft. Und nicht recht wissen, was man überhaupt darf. Darf man jetzt einem Spieler verbieten, öffentlich über seinen Glauben, auch wenn er diskriminierend ist, zu sprechen oder nicht? Ich denke, das sind so ein bisschen die Gründe. Und es gibt da einerseits eben die Vereine sind in der Pflicht, die Spieler zu schützen, aufzuklären zu solchen Themen. Eine andere Plattform zu nehmen, also den Glauben und das Bedürfnis zu glauben, ernst nehmen und das ein bisschen zu leiten, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Und andererseits halt auch wirklich solche diskriminierenden Aussagen, auch wenn sie in der Bibel stehen, zu benennen und zu beurteilen.
Man könnte ja sogar das jetzt noch einen Schritt weitergedacht. Man kann ja auch diese christlichen, diese christlichen Aussagen aus der Bibel, die selbst kann man ja auch in den Kontext setzen. Denn das, finde ich, ist das Interessante. Wir werden dazu verleitet, dadurch, dass wir diesen Menschen jetzt in dieser Sendung so viel zugehört haben und so viel mit ihm beschäftigt haben. Irgendwann interpretiert man auch jeden Satz, so wie in der Bibel steht. Und dann vergisst man eben genau das, was eigentlich alle Theologen, die eben nicht zu solchen evangelikalischen oder charismatischen oder pfingstlichen Bewegungen gehören. Niemand versteht die Bibel absolut wörtlich. Sie wird immer in einen Kontext gesetzt. In den Kontext der Zeit, zum Beispiel, gibt es viele Theologinnen und Theologen, die alles, was über Homosexualität in der Bibel gesagt wird, auch darunter verstehen, dass Homosexualität damals auch bedeutet hat, dass man Ehebruch begangen hat und dass es eben nicht um eine langfristige Beziehung ging, um ein gemeinsames Leben, sondern, also jetzt ganz verkürzt gesagt, um den Seitensprung und vielleicht auch daher so manche Formulierung in der Bibel kam. Da wird natürlich endlos drüber gestritten und es ist schwierig und letztlich ist es eine mündlich überlieferte Geschichte, die irgendwann verschriftlicht wurde. Aber sogar das wäre ja möglich. Man könnte ja als Verein auch so etwas anbieten, sich darüber in den Austausch zu begeben. Und wenn du dann feststellst, dass gegenüber in dem Fall dann ein Spieler oder ein Trainer, eine Trainerin, die machen zu und die vertreten eine radikale Auslegung des Christentums, die sich eben mit unseren Grundrechten, mit dem Grundgesetz widerspricht, dann hast du ja auch eine Legitimation zu handeln und vielleicht daraus auch Konsequenzen zu ziehen. Und das finde ich immer wieder bemerkenswert, dass es eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig ist, die Werte, die man vorgibt, dann auch zu leben. Und du bist dafür, wenn du für eine diskriminierungsfreie Welt bist, und das würde jeder Verein von sich behaupten, jeder Verband behauptet das von sich, jede Liga behauptet das von sich aktuell, hier in Deutschland zumindest, dann bist du ja dazu verpflichtet, den entsprechenden Safe Space für alle betroffenen Gruppen zu schaffen. Und wenn du das konsequent durchsetzt, dann müsstest du eigentlich auch automatisch sehr unattraktiv sein für Menschen, denen das komplett gegen den Strich geht. Also man könnte auch, glaube ich, über so fast wie ein magnetisches Feld, das sich aufbaut. Und gewisse Dinge kannst du dann damit gar nicht mehr anziehen, die stößt du ab, nämlich den genauen Gegenpol dazu. Ich weiß nicht, Felix, ob das jetzt irgendwie zu utopisch ist, ob das zu metaphorisch gedacht ist. Ich fühle mich gerade wie Christian Ilzer, sorry. Aber so könnte man dem Ganzen ja auch begegnen. Lebt eure Werte halt auch im Alltag?
Auf jeden Fall. Es ist wahrscheinlich schon utopisch. Ich halte es nicht für realistisch, dass es jetzt passieren wird. Der zentrale Konflikt, der wahrscheinlich bei vielen Vereinen ist, zeigt sich auch wieder an Nmecha. Nmecha liefert ja absolute Leistung bei BVB jetzt die letzten Jahre. Und da ist eben dieser Konflikt, was soll man mit jemandem machen, der im Fußball Leistung bringt. Es geht um Leistung, Punkt. Das ist vielleicht nochmal eine andere Sache. Es gibt ja offensichtlich dieses Bedürfnis nach Spiritualität. Das ist, was ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe, was ist jetzt fast schon eine philosophische Frage, aber was ja scheinbar menschen verankert ist, sicherlich auch bei FußballerInnen. Und da sollten die Vereine und Verbände meiner Meinung nach dafür sorgen, dass für Fußballinnen, auch Nachwuchsfußballinnen, es irgendwelche Angebote gibt, die außerhalb dieser Kreise, außerhalb dieser zumindest mal dubiosen Kreise gibt, um es vorsichtig zu formulieren. Das gibt es sicherlich schon, aber irgendwas hindert es ja daran, also irgendwas hindert die FußballerInnen ja daran, dahin zu gehen, statt irgendwie sich dubiosen Netzwerken anzuschließen. Was auch immer die Komponente jetzt sein mag.
Zu diesem utopischen Szenario, was ich ziemlich geil fände, man kann es ein bisschen mit St. Pauli vergleichen. St. Pauli lebt ja eigentlich seine Werte ziemlich öffentlich aus und auch verreinsintern, so was ich halt so mitkriege. Und selbst sie haben Mitglieder von Ballers in God, die bei ihm spielen, die bei ihm gespielt haben. Zum Beispiel Eric da Silva Moreira, oder wie man es ausspricht. Ist ja auch DFB-Nationalspieler. Und es hat ihn auch nicht davon abgehalten, obwohl er in diesem sehr offenen Verein groß geworden ist, zu Ballers in God zu gehen. Ich weiss nicht, ob das alleine reicht. Aber ich denke, es würde natürlich die Einflussnahme ein bisschen bremsen. Von diesen Communities.
Ja, und ich glaube, so ein bisschen kann man Gedanken durch den Bärenfall bei Wolfsburg. Also wenn sich ein Spieler weigert, ein Regenbogentrikot zu unterschreiben und indem er das auch beschimpft und verunglimpft, dann ist es ja, also dann alles, was danach gekommen ist, muss thematisiert werden. Also dass das erst intern gelöst werden sollte und der VfL Wolfsburg schon ein bisschen öffentlich Druck gebraucht hat, sich dazu zu verhalten. Aber das eigentlich Gute ist ja, dass dieser Spieler dieses Regenbogentrikot unterschreiben sollte, denn da hat sich seine Gesinnung gezeigt. Das ist ihm gegen den Strich gegangen. Wenn er das Szeneknischen signiert, ist mir das ja auch völlig egal, weil damit wird ja gezeigt, das ist halt einfach, wir glauben daran. Ich meine, ich würde das jetzt auch gar nicht auf dieses Symbol der Regenbogenflagge, da könnte man jetzt auch ganz lange drüber sprechen, wie man das persönlich findet. Aber das meine ich, konfrontiert einfach Menschen mit einer gelebten Realität, die eben diskriminierungsfrei ist. Und dann glaube ich, dass klar, kannst du dann immer noch ein Baller in Gott sein. Es kann auch sein, dass du das alles erträgst. Aber dann ist ja eigentlich auch nichts passiert, denn wir wollen ja eine diskriminierungsfreie Welt. Und nur darauf haben wir ja auch einen Anspruch. Was jeder Mensch für sich glaubt, das haben wir ja schon oft genug jetzt gesagt. Es ist ja seine oder ihre Sache. Felix, du wolltest was ergänzen?
Ja, ich habe eine gute Idee. Gebt Felix Nmecha doch einfach mal eine Regenbogenkapitän. Das würde mal schauen, was dann passiert. Das wäre ja genau die Taktik, die du jetzt beschreibst.
Ich möchte mich dazu nicht weiter äußern.
Ich bringe es in den Raum, also ich finde es auch nicht schlecht.
Wir denken nur, so wie die lieben Ballers in Gott einfach nur beten.
Kann man so sagen.
Ihr zwei, das war eine anspruchsvolle Sendung. Auch, weil wir hier ein paar technische Probleme hatten. Also liebe YouTube-Zusehende, da gab es so den einen oder anderen Schnitt. Das hatte hier mit sehr, sehr wankelmütigem Internet zu tun. Dina hat vorhin schon in einer der Unterbrechungen gesagt, da ist uns der Heilige Geist ins W-Lang gefahren. Vielleicht war das, war dem auch so. Dem spüren wir nach. Ich danke euch beiden sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit, für eure Recherchen. Wie gesagt, nochmal der Hinweis. Ich werde alles verlinken, wo man das lesen kann. Und ich kann alle Zuhörenden da draußen nur auffordern, bleibt an dem Thema dran, denn es hat eine ganz eigene Dynamik. Das habt ihr an den Followerzahlen, die wir vorhin immer mal wieder haben fallen lassen, gemerkt. Die sind rasant gestiegen in den letzten Monaten. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Dina Falken. Dina, danke, dass du dich des Themas angenommen hast und hier im Rasenfunk warst.
Sehr gerne.
Und herzlichen Dank an Felix Michaelis. Schön, dass du hier mit dabei warst, Felix. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, was ihr noch so alles rausrecherchiert in der Zukunft.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Habe mich gefreut.
Mich ebenso. Und dann danke ich natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern. Denn ihr wisst ja, eine Sendung wie diese hier, paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei, die ist nur durch euch möglich. Alles hier im Rasenfunk ist von euch finanziert. Dementsprechend können wir auch den unabhängigsten Journalismus umsetzen, den man sich vorstellen kann. Also hier spricht niemand in die Themenfindung mit rein. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns unterstützt haben. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr in der Video- und der Podcastbeschreibung. Oder wenn ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht und dort auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Läuft bei mir, Daniel, bei Henning, bei Nils, bei Bananenflanke123 und bei Les-Inc. Sie alle haben sich auch als Supportende registriert und so konnte ich sie hier nach dem Zufallsprinzip nennen. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, dann sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de versucht, die Grautöne zu sehen. Auch die Grautöne, die wir hier in unserer Diskussion hatten. Und dann bin ich aber sehr gespannt, was ihr zu dieser Sendung hier sagt. Würde mich freuen, wenn ihr den Rasenfunk weiterempfehlt, diese Sendung hier weiterempfehlt und hört auch gerne in unsere anderen Formate rein. In diesem Sinne, bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.
Ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Psst, Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knauser.
Genau.